on a list of historically bad ideas
japan's decision to bomb po harbour
always gets an honorable mention given
that for japan the outcome was not
exactly a positive one
it's natural to ask what its leaders
hope to achieve so why
why did japan bomb pearl harbor so
before talking about the attack itself
it's important to look at what the
japanese government's long-term plans
were for the country
japan is not a resource-rich country and
so in order to secure long-term security
in terms of things like oil and food
japan sought to expand its borders and
create what was known as the greater
east asia co-prosperity sphere
an empire which would see japan as the
hegemon of asia in the pacific
by 1939 japan had already achieved some
of its expansion and was in control of
manchuria as well as waging war against
china for more territory with respect to
further expansion the japanese
government had two
options the first was the northern plan
favored by the japanese army
this argued for the invasion of the ussr
via manchuria in order to secure the
land and resources of siberia whilst
also grabbing mongolia
and much of china the idea was that
communism was the biggest threat to
japan and that the western powers would
do little to nothing in the defense of
the ussr
plan number two was the southern plan
favored by the navy
this would see japan strike southwards
and take the american and european
colonies in southeast asia notably
indonesia to secure their abundant
resources
this would inevitably lead to
confrontation with the world's imperial
powers and as such was seen as the much
riskier option but to the navy the us
was japan's biggest threat
so when border skirmishes broke out with
the ussr the japanese army didn't
perform all too well and as a result the
japanese government saw the army as
incapable of fulfilling the northern
plan
whereas the navy was still seen as
incredibly prestigious and thus their
plan won
out the decision to strike south was
accelerated in 1941 when the usa placed
an oil embargo against japan
something that the americans said would
only end if japan abandoned its war with
china and its gains in indochina
surely japan's southern ambitions could
be fulfilled without dragging the us
into war right
well no whilst the u.s public was
against intervention roosevelt made it
clear that much of the region was under
u.s protection
so why attack pearl harbor especially
given the size of america's navy in its
unmatched industrial base
well to be clear the japanese did not
believe that they could win a long
drawn-out war against the united states
and so the japanese government decided
that since war with the u.s was
inevitable that victory needed to be won
with a single decisive strike which
would [ __ ] the us navy
the idea was that with the u.s navy
crippled it would allow time for south
asia to be conquered
and such events would then knock
american confidence so badly that its
people would sue for peace
not everybody in the japanese government
thought that this was a good idea though
and many made clear that they would lose
any war long or short with the united
states they did it anyway and we all
know what happened
and the reasons were simple they felt
that they had to and importantly
they thought that they'd win i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons
james bissonette sam kelly money maker
the pastry section danny maloney moe
marvin cassell rob waterhouse james
castaneda jordan longley spinning three
plates gustav swan jerry lamdin rasheed
ali marcus asner izzy maggie paxkowski
cooling castleman david silverman
coppertone anthony beckett matthew
shipley
lexi schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle winston cayward aaron the
white spencer lightfoot and fobo joe